tension on the set of a christmas movie
who butted heads to keep an elf sequal
from happening the answer is actually
pretty surprising elf sue will never
happen keep watching to find out why
comedy legend while farrell's career has
had its shares of ups and downs but when
it comes to christmas comedy elf the
actor delivered some serious holiday
cheer directed by john favreau and
written by david berenbaum the 2003 film
quickly became a hit both critics and
audiences applauded the film for his
blend of endearing goofball humor which
is evidenced by its 85 critic score and
79 audience score on rotten tomatoes the
movie stars feral as buddy a human
accidentally transported to the north
pole as a baby who now works as one of
santa's helpers among his army of elves
after discovering his true identity one
christmas buddy heads to new york city
to meet his biological father the result
is equal parts funny and heartwarming
now considered a christmas classic the
cast includes hollywood icons ed asner
and bob newhart who star as sansa and
buddy's adoptive elf father respectively
meanwhile zoe deschanel plays farrell's
love interest mary steenbergen plays
buddy's stepmom and daniel tayyis a
stepbrother the part of buddy's
biological father is played by the
incomparable james khan unsurprisingly
the movie has inspired impassioned calls
for a sequel for years yet it's never
happened in 2020 khan gave an incredibly
insightful interview about elf even
explaining the reason we'll likely never
see a sequel according to the actor
tension and personality clashes between
the film star will ferrell and its
director john favreau means that fans
will probably never see the beloved cast
reunite on the big screen in an
impromptu interview with local radio
show 92.3 bull and fox khan revealed the
director john favreau and will didn't
get along very well so will wanted to do
it he didn't want the director and he
had it in his contract it was one of
those things that's that's ridiculous
khan only ended up appearing on the
radio show after his assistant who is
from cleveland called into bull and fox
to discuss the brown's most recent win
the actor eventually joined the
conversation delighting fans by sharing
that an elf sequel very nearly happened
and that he had been ready to sign on
this was of course a major shift from
his reluctance to appear in the first
film khan told the radio show hosts that
he had initially turned down the request
to play farrell's father all right uh
let's get it over with
as khan said will called me one night
and said jimmy want to do this picture
with me
can't reply to farrell's request
negatively at first saying listen will i
love you you're a funny guy but i'm not
doing a picture called elf okay khan
said he negotiated to change the film
title to elk on the working scripts as a
condition of his casting adding i said
i'll tell you what if you put a k on the
end of it like just through the working
scripts then i'll do it it was great fun
with will he's a great guy following the
incredible success of elf the actor
shared that he was ready for a sequel
despite the film's two biggest creatives
butting heads khan revealed we were
gonna do it and i thought oh my god i
finally got a franchise movie i could
make some money let my kids do what the
hell they want to do however personality
clashes may not be the only reason we
haven't seen an elf two yet both favreau
and farrow keep pretty busy the director
is currently attached to several disney
projects including season three of the
mandalorian meanwhile the saturday night
live alum continues his on-screen work
in surprise hits like eurovision song
contest the story of fire saga as he
juggles producing obligations on
projects like succession and dead to me
sadly it seems like the odds of an elf 2
occurring just got even lower as james
khan tragically passed away on july 6
2022. khan's straight man to feral's
crazy man turned elf was a big reason
why the film was so hilarious and
touching and it's hard to imagine anyone
else occupying his role it appears as
though elf is destined to be a one and
done type project at least fans can take
solace and knowing all the right puzzle
pieces came together at one place in
time to deliver a genuine christmas
classic check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one